écoutez on va voir justement ce que vous
seriez prête à faire ou pas par amour
parce que c'est important que les
français souhaitent au courant ça
s'appelle l'interview par amour et vous
savez que vous il ya deux connards de
rebelles ce soir malheureusement que le
cadreur et bassiste et qui bouge la
caméra passe donc par amour est ce que
vous seriez prête à sacrifier vos
ambitions professionnelles
vous y croyez toujours vrai amour c'est
bien heureusement heureusement sillage
il se répand dans madame la baronne de
répondre alors quand est-ce que par
amour
vous seriez prête à refuser un film avec
steven spielberg pour l'amour pour tous
pour votre fiancée vous dis je refuse
que tu tournes avec vous et c'est
exactement la théorie de madame la
baronne qui dit quand on aime quelqu'un
on a de la chance ce soir m deux femmes
très très compréhensifs
j'espère que les autres en prendront
intelligente site où vous avez raison en
baroeul est-ce que par amour vous
retourneriez vivre en république tchèque
non sens à toute la technologie
je crois que c'est
on trouve là nous et nous ramène au
monde d'accord bien est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à vous faire refaire
les seins
non ce ne sera pas un bon encore
ouais c'est pas un vrai amour un type
qui demanderaient du goba je fais à
faire les choses pour un connard du tout
préparé un vrai amour est-ce que par
amour vous seriez prête à ne pas faire
d'enfant ça c'est difficile
un mec qui vous dit je t'aime on se
marie mais moi je déteste les enfants
j'en veux pas c'est pas possible c'est
lé fruit de l'amour donc c'est
automatique c'est naturel que ça vient
est-ce que par amour vous aideriez votre
votre homme a caché le corps de
quelqu'un qu'il vient de tuer et vous
aussi oui ouais mais vous préférez
mais oui après j'ai écrit un livre
là-dessus ouais l'avantagé la
littérature c'est que tout semble avoir
un sens subitement alors ça c'est une
question importante c'est la question de
clotilde courau clotilde courau qui est
une jeune actrice très talentueuse
d'ailleurs nous a dit que par amour
quand elle était plus jeune elle
embrasse et 100 fois de suite les
chaussettes sales de son fiancé c'est
possible vous le feriez vous à vous non
vous avez jamais eu les cheveux c'est
pas le pire un barreau ne peut dire à
nadine vous avez jamais vécu que le
batteur de bonnes choses
avec boris vian c'est vrai dans nadine
donc l'avenir amour il devait avoir 25
ans et j'en avais celle d'eva herzigova
est-ce que par amour vous accepteriez
que votre fiancée et une maîtresse
j'aurais mal à se porter j'aurais
j'aurais très mal oui mais si vous
voulez mais vraiment voulu qu'il soit
heureux mais c'est éduquer leurs
habitudes je suis compliqué
éventuellement 6,6 il amène sa maîtresse
et que vous faites un truc à 3 à st pas
lasser mais ça c est pas besoin d'être
assistées après on fait pas est sur le
point d'être 8 en plaine mais google a
pas besoin d'être assistés à son âge
bon oui mais un peu comme ça quand même
envisager la la la c'est par les déchets
près d'evry cambon qui s'ignorent ne dit
c'est pas non est-ce que par amour ou
seriez prête à aller dans une boîte
échangiste tous les samedis soirs
oui on y va ce soir
non non un samedi sur deux à un samedi
sur deux
tous les 15 jours parce que je pense à
l'amour et si j'aimais vraiment qu
est-ce qui ça apporte le mec fait ce
qu'il veut c'est la groupe et il sait
pas mais c'est en fait ces enfants est
un fantasme c'est que là une partie de
cet homme je sais pas c mais non ça ne
se plierait pas à ces quatre conscience
a quand même un ace que par un mot vous
seriez prête à devenir son esclave
sexuelle et la france entière bons gags
- ghislain
frédéric hallucinant c'est cet homme qui
réalise ans qui arrive à imposer qu'on
soit fier des trucs de malade
les cinq mois il faut le savoir est ce
que par amour nous sourire est prête à
grossir de 10 kg si le type aime bien
les rues basses et forme êtes d'accord
nous élevons par amour aussi de 10 kilos
ça tu appelles tomber enceinte